talk about what signs the conversations
you had with Bob as far as what you were
supposed to do when you had nothing to
say it was a very different movie for me
because I had done some really big
budget in movies paternity with Burt
Reynolds
I didn't we've called honky tonk freeway
directed by John Schlesinger these were
massive movies that were gonna be huge
hits they were flying out bombs but they
were full of all the hype on movie sets
of this is going to make your kid and
all that and this was very refreshing
because it was a low-budget movie but
Bob Clarke and gene Shepard who wrote
the source material and wrote the script
with Bob for it had worked for 12 years
to get the movie made so the level of
preparation and they had to agree to do
other things for the studio to get it
made the level of preparation on this
set I had never been around and you
could feel it and Bob had the whole
movie on note cards which you probably
remember that he had and he had it not
only shot listed but the framing that he
wanted notes to himself about
performances and this was before video
tap most directors now stick behind
you've seen it on sets right they said
behind the screen they watch so his face
was right next to the mat box to the
camera so I had to learn not to have
that be distracting first off because he
was right there but he would read the
narration not gene in the cadence that
he felt it was ultimately going to be in
the movie and then sometimes would just
go off book from the narration and just
talk to me about what you might be
feeling so it was actually sort of like
having a subconscious so as I was
working he was my interior monologue in
many ways so it helped I think get the
performance and he was very demanding in
a good way I think to get the
performances that he wanted so it was a
fun movie to work on because it was
challenging it was the weather it was
cold it was outside there were things
that you couldn't solve by writing a
check I was up in Canada I didn't live
in California at the time so there was a
technical thing where the child labor
laws I think I was doing 12 hours a day
at the time which was fine
because if I got tired he'd let me go
home it was that kind of a set and it
you've kind of valued the always
described as sort of that take your
lunch pail to work kind of set where the
work was paying off now the tone seemed
crazy so
time's the blind guy he and the Cowboys
and nobody quite knew but Bob and Jean
just knew and to have Melinda and Darrin
on set as well
so this those a lot of those scenes were
when I was conspiring to get the gun and
with Bob but to have them on set as such
great leaders for us for kids cuz we
were still kids we were 12 in Tannen 8
and we were wild probably inappropriate
or running around and you know not as
disciplined as we should be but they
said such a great tone of warmth and of
leadership and I remember Melinda
feeling like my mom in those moments and
Darrin feeling like a dad
and so those performances just drew you
in as an actor and it just really helped
set the tone on the set for so many of
those scenes and I think you said it in
the opening without them I don't think
you have the same movie you know